Nelson it's great to be here with you
and get to talk about your work war
against all Puerto Ricans I wanted to
start with something that you say in the
introduction to the book and I'm going
to quote you you say that most of us
have a personal connection to the work
that we do and that we set out a new set
out to discover your family and not only
our families but our Puerto Ricans and I
think that is true for those of us who
were born in the island as well as for
those of us who were born here and I
would like to talk about the discovery
of your family can you tell me about
that well mine was a small nuclear
family um I was born here in New York
living in Washington Heights
my mother was she wrote the book on my
mother was from Caguas Puerto Rico and
my father was Cuban and I was the only
child and it was a small but
hard-working unit and my my father was a
very Pro Castro and we would have
meetings he would have like 10 or 15
people on Saturday nights and would my
mother would make thick black coffee and
it was bundled on and was exciting for
me because I would hear oh you know
there's all these really excited
conversations and about politics Latin
America he liked Castro which a lot of
people hadn't heard about but he was
like all the talking in my house but I
have an early lesson in the value of
family and the importance of maintaining
it because the FBI came during the
shortly after the Cuban Missile Crisis
crisis October and November of 62 about
3:00 or 4:00 in the morning I was 8
years old at the time and they took my
father away they deported into Cuba
without any process or administrative
protocol that I was aware of he was gone
and when we never saw him again that was
our family was permanently ruptured so I
my family the side that I grew up
knowing was my mother's side of the
family that was you know by definition
my father was gone and unfortunately
that
politics had an early impact in my life
and actually that factored into my my
wanting to write this book eventually
when I saw hundreds of FBI files and
that made me recall how my father had
been affected by the FBI so only child
became a really good student I didn't
feel there's any margin for error my
mother and I know luckily she was
working in the belt factories in the
garment center and I was just a good
student and they're very curious and
when I got scholarships I went to
Harvard being Puerto Rican I was curious
about Pedro Albizu Campos and he was the
first Puerto Rican to graduate from
Harvard Harvard Law School but I went to
Widener Library the pantheon no Pantheon
books have 57 miles of books at the time
in the card catalog and in the wall
there I went through was eight nine
floors of Widener it wasn't one book on
Pedro Albizu Campos and I found that
striking and it's anything that incited
my curiosity at a point and in college I
found for me college at least at Harvard
was a had an abundance of options and
opportunities but not much guidance you
have to pretty much find your own way
yeah and it's a great place for a
self-starter I took a year off to find
some of that and I spent the bulk of it
in visiting family in Puerto Rico
particularly in Caguas and I encountered
a nationalist in my family who had known
Peggy Sue couple's pretty well he was
one of his bodyguards for a period of
time when he came back in 1948 and so
one meeting left led to another I got I
started hearing things that were
soundings but like a James Bond movie uh
the things that were going on in Puerto
Rico it was not fully documented at the
time because the FBI was maintaining the
secret police files called Kotter
pickups on over a hundred thousand Porto
Ricans but they have not yet
then disclosed they had been
declassified until the year 2000 but in
1974 I was getting it firsthand from the
people that had lived it some of the
people that had gone to prison
people that knew IVs examples personally
people that knew beyond Santiago Diaz
the famous barber who waged a gunfight
at salon boricua this tremendous stories
are and it all was I could there were a
lot of dots and I was connecting about
one common denominator was I seem to be
a sort of a persistent and perhaps
unwitting and that's the nature of
empire that things are done sometimes
almost through by default you just major
power simply has to be and impose itself
by or by sheer gravitational pull it can
infiltrate an entire culture and it
gives a little bit also do it a little
bit more intentionally like in Pablo
fighters of pedagogy oppressed you start
to see how specifically a dominant
society can impose its version of of
cultural identity and and
self-determination on another on another
country sure well I became aware how
that elements of what is the island what
is the history what is the culture was
being had been systematically
obliterated and sometimes not through
any specific sense and there were
different people that did that
participating that versus there was a
guy who Commissioner of Education I
forget his name but he wrote a book that
was the textbook on Puerto Rican history
for about thirty years from 1930 about
20 years from 1930 to about 1952 and it
really was a hagiography for the United
States um but it just gave a one-sided
version of history when Portland the
United States first arrived there they
tried to eliminate Spanish in the school
and that that didn't last long so so I
became aware that there was an element
natural human resistance to being denied
who you are and I saw that in the
stories certainly in the life of Ibiza
Campos mm-hmm great and I think that you
mentioned on visa was as a major player
in the story and he is a major player in
the story and you say that the story of
Albizu Campos is the story of Puerto
Rico and why don't you tell us a little
bit about that well - solid Puerto Rico
um United States occupied in 1898 the
next very next of squattin nineteen nine
hurricane sandy vehicle one of the most
devastating hurricanes in its history
devastated the islands agriculture the
coffee crop was about 50 million pounds
were gone tens of thousands of feet of
people left homeless and the United
States didn't really send out any any
meaningful relief this was in 1899 but
instead in the following year in 1900 it
declared that the United States dollar
was the only currency to be used in
Puerto Rico to Puerto Rican petrol was
no longer valid and it had to be a
currency exchange but the two currencies
which were roughly equivalent of equal
buying power internationally were not
we're not equally weren't exchanged on
an equal basis in what everything might
be valid yes yeah each photo Rican
dollar would be worth about 60 American
cents by the end of the transaction
that's a 40 percent devaluation of every
person you think about the the the World
Trade Center 9/11 tragedy it was
terrible it was two very large buildings
their largest buildings but at the end
of the day was two buildings and look at
the ripple effect that it had to our
society our economy the globe global
infrastructure homeland security a whole
new set of repercussions that was it -
Billy think about what would happen in
the United States if everybody woke up
one day and 40% of their property
holdings of their real estate anything
that was never gone and uncommon early
their debts had gone up by
what a present it will be a social shut
down the what's happening in Baltimore
right now would be a microcosm of what
we would be seeing in every city this
society would cease to exist as we know
it well that's what happened in Puerto
Rico so you have a hurricane in one year
currency devaluation the following year
and the year after that to the Hollander
act you had a steeply graduated set of
property taxes that hit all the farmers
in Puerto Rico that they never they
never faced before you have this
economic trifecta that happens in at the
outset of the relationship with the
United States there was a great degree
of dislocation farmers lost their farms
farmers tried to hold on to their farms
the tobacco grow that you know a lot of
a great deal rot or successful of subtle
added they were also they had I think
we're a bit more versatile because had
smaller holdings so it was it was more
it was doable with a struggle they they
to their credit they did it yeah but you
have farmers that are desperately trying
to hold on to the farms they take out
loans there was no user resolved
restriction and interestingly the the
major the second largest bank in eight
in 1901 was the American colonial bank
great name within twenty years it was
the largest bank it held title to all
these properties there was note without
use real all restrictions farmers
started defaulting on their loans all
over the island it magnified the
mortgage crisis of 2007 a hundredfold so
within 10 or 20 years what you have is
an internal Diaspora but occurring
already people are being separated from
their land and no longer even
sharecroppers because a lot of that land
is being now turned into a one crop cash
cow economy with notable exceptions but
there was a tremendous dominance of the
sugar economy and this exotic so now you
have people that were formerly farmers
self-sufficient the diversified
agriculture looking for work they
migrate to the cities understandably
they try to enact minimum minimum wage
legislation but because the United
States has plenary jurisdiction over any
law passed by a Puerto Rican legislature
it was struck down and interestingly
this happened in the early 20s in 1917
Puerto Ricans were declared US citizens
in
two of 1917 and exactly one month later
exactly on April 2nd 1917 Woodrow Wilson
sent his declaration awards the United
States Congress
so it seems fair it's not a large
inferential leap to say that Puerto
Ricans were declared US citizens in time
for military conscription into World War
one
sure be and you know that's a really
interesting point and something that
scholars have been dealing with for a
while and I think that the idea that
that that the Jones Act that that the
importance of citizenship for the Jones
Act was going to be the eventual
drafting of Puerto Ricans into the war
has been questioned by a lot of scholars
recently and one of the one of the
arguments against that is that Puerto
Ricans were considered as a since the
Foraker Act was passed in 1900 they were
considered US Nationals and that yeren
US Nationals could be drafted into war
in other words if you were a u.s.
national you didn't need to be a citizen
to be drafted so that in fact
citizenship in terms of War draft would
not have been a major motivation to the
Jones Act well that's a good point very
important but there are enforcement
provisions that go along with with
citizenship and so I would counter that
the fact that you tell that to Puerto
Ricans who are down in the island who
understand the meaning of citizenship
and a part of it is also social
conditioning once you feel that yours is
you feel obligated because a lot of it
is voluntary compliance you have to show
it we're talking at that point about
close to a million out for 2 million
Puerto Ricans so although that's
something that I would explore and that
you know you're you know sort of a case
in first impression I will simply submit
that it just added to the weight of the
of the of the of the the conditioning
that you're going to have to show up to
the Selective Service and now because
you were citizen and so that's number
one number two it became immediately
qualified five years later when they
tried to enact minimum wage legislation
and Congress one didn't veto that number
one and two on the back before Puerto
Rico in 1922 it was ruled that since
unite the Oporto Rico was an uncaught
territory of the United States the US
Constitution did not apply and the
quote-unquote citizens of Puerto Rico
did not have any of the privileges and
immunities of being a citizen so
therefore let's reverse engineer the
situation given the fact that you're
declared a citizen in 1917 but you
denied any of the essential elements of
citizenship which is the protection of
the US Constitution and you can back
yourself into the into the scenario well
then why were you declared a citizens in
1917 if not to provide you any
protections if you don't even have First
Amendment rights because public law 53
withdrew them in 1948 if you have to if
you have to petition the US Congress for
any law which can be vetoed unilaterally
by Congress the United States presidency
well you've really been given an empty
shell of a citizenship however you were
able to go go fight in World War one but
for me the scenario is very clear and
that's something I could you know
research and spend another two years of
my life never ending this stuff is all
never ending so now we're getting to as
far as I'll be so IV fou graduates
during that period go to go to Harvard
and Harvard Law School was a person kind
of injured in World War one but he comes
back during the height of this
concentration of wealth and power in in
Puerto Rico and starts rapidly to see he
becomes parts a one-man law office in
[ __ ] a single leadership of the
nationalist party was voted as president
and very quickly he sees that there is a
sort of an invidious one-sided
relationship between the United States
and Puerto Rico as a highly trained
lawyer he knows the meaning of Balzac V
Puerto Rico he understands the meaning
of being quote unquote a citizen and not
having any of the privileges and
immunities so he advocates organizers
editorialize --is for years about the
independence of Puerto Rico but the
United States doesn't really doesn't
matter I and like I signed up or nothing
and they say they know him in his own
house it only that comes to an immediate
immediate
becomes a focal point when he leaves an
island-wide agricultural strike in 1933
1934 and at that point it ended up the
net result of which was doubling the
sugarcane workers wages from roughly 75
cents a day to a dollar 50 day for a
10-hour days was about seven and a half
cents the fifteen cents an hour that was
massive that was the difference between
starvation and not it was huge to end it
within the depth of the of the Great
Depression
this is 1934 well that's where the story
of Albizu Campos is the story of Puerto
Rico because at that moment a precise
event is when Wall Street and Washington
finally recognized that there was
something happening in Puerto Rico
finally it became a stone in the shoe of
the powers of power that be they there
was an immediate reaction they sent a
new new governor Blanton Winship when he
was a US Army General a new police chief
chief Francis Riggs Yale graduate had
been a military adjutant in Nicaragua is
sort of like a sort of a double-oh-seven
type going to different countries
everywhere he go though there would be a
destabilized regime behind well II
Francis Riggs father was the president
of the Riggs National Bank the Riggs
Bank was at the core of financing a lot
of the destabilizing of these regimes
back to words filibusters interesting
the word filibuster originally meant to
go down to south of Central American
country and start a fake revolution that
was a disguised right-wing takeover that
would put in install a tin pot dictator
that was friendly to United States
interest now is called filibustering so
Riggs came over to over basically oh not
just be the police chief of Puerto Rico
but to oversee the rig's the rig's
investments in they had investments all
over the South and Central America but
he was basically coming in as a colonial
overseer for that financing that Wall
Street conglomerate of which the Riggs
Bank was apart rigged
in a very famous meeting with Ivies
examples during the height of the
agricultural strike he invited obvious
examples to meeting areas and let's come
wrong very elegant restaurant in someone
at which and there were multiple
witnesses and it was reported and in
Pascal written about by various
biographers he just made a naked offer
of the bribe $150,000 offered to a
little compost if you would basically
back off of the agricultural strike and
kind of saw pedal tone down his
nationalist demands okay
essentially to just stop being what he
was which is an advocate for the
independence of Puerto Rico IV su of
mildly but firmly very politely said
that Island wasn't for sale II and and
in left for luncheon it was right then
that the reprisal setting because first
they tried would be that very plan a
when the bribe didn't work plan D well
actually did a little more to $150 they
also shows gave him a path to becoming
the majority leader of the Senate so it
was a pretty nice a nice attractive
package it was the equivalent amount
quarantine eeeh with it devil takes you
to the top of the mountain that says all
this will be yours
you'll just wanna come with me so
obviously turn that down but that deal
was basically offered if you look at the
history of it to least one knows money
he took the deal and he went that way
and he you know he under he developed
that American embrace for the following
25 years of his life to the point where
he was a sponsor of law 53 and all sorts
of repressive legislation in Puerto Rico
to make sure that nobody complained
about me about the United States so
Albizu walks away from that meeting with
Riggs the violence begins almost
immediately Oh Steve I mean so
harassment all over the island
assassination threats and assassination
attempts for three nationalists and a
guy buying a lottery ticket with an
innocent bystander were shot and he
opiate us in October 1935 in what was
became known as that he opiate Alice
Massacre and immediately thereafter if
they are shot by policemen the police
chiefs Riggs held a press conference
convene the press brought them in
because he wanted specifically to get to
enunciate these words when asked what's
going on
what can you contextualize and explain
these open open air in the middle of the
day assassinations and he said it's very
simple if Ivies examples and the
nationalist continue to agitate the
sugarcane workers and university
students there's going to be war to the
death against all Puerto Ricans and at
least within a few days later I think a
few days later made a speech that was
then reprinted where he says you know
Riggs has made the call for war and I
will answer that call with war and he
said he uses the same language war
against all Yankees yeah the album you
had was when someone is coming after you
to basically kill you you have to say
I'm not really messing up yes I was yeah
I mention it was done at the UM at the
funeral for Edie for the three deceased
and it was about if you see the pictures
of twenty thousand people surrounding
the uh the the funeral at Carolina and
the bathro brothers the Nationalist
Party had one old World War One biplane
and they opened on that event where I'll
be so spoke they flew over the cemetery
and they dropped white lilies over the
of the people those there's a hot one
real memorable moment so that's what I
chose as a title for my book because it
bespoke a and that not just the
utterance of the words but the fact that
you will say that to an entire people to
natales just naked Lee it's equivalent
to Bull Connor in in the
african-american civil rights era and in
a certain perverse way people started to
appreciate Bull Connor because he was so
open and and declarative you you could
appreciate Bull Connor to be Bull Connor
Bull Connor would bring out the fire
hydrants and the dogs and give the best
photo-op imaginable so that people could
naked Lee see what was going on in the
South exactly and and and it it Burton
Lee helped the civil rights movement but
so it with the prism and the hind side
of history
it actually you know it's beneficial
that we know now that this is the way
they were rolling in Puerto Rico okay
there's going to be if you this is how
it is this is the sugarcane strip we
don't want to shoot we want to pay you
these wages if you don't like it we're
going to shoot you
and if you don't like that we're gonna
shoot you some more and it's called a
war against all Puerto Ricans the fact
that the police chief of Puerto Rico
would say that to the islands press is a
Moute one of the clearest expressions of
empire and so that was where the the
story about these examples became highly
joined with with the story of Puerto
Rico because his life was defined his
life in fact was defined by leadership
or the leadership role that he played in
that agricultural strike tank because it
was then that the violence began and it
was then that the charges of seditious
conspiracy against the United States
again
he hasn't spending twenty five years in
jail when he was four nineteen thirty
six to sixty five is twenty nine years
right so shortly after the agricultural
strike he's in jail as a thirty-six so
you do the math 25 years in jail leaves
in four years four years at that time
and those four years you surrounded and
followed by a platoon of FBI agents we
have four or five round-the-clock and to
maintain that troop strength you have to
have about twenty FBI agents assigned
from because if it's round the clock
yeah so twenty FBI is assigned to one
man and on top of that when he got out
of jail in 1948 after having spent the
first ten years in jail in December of
47 by June of 48 they passed the law law
53 I lay that I mourn after a law of the
muzzle which made it illegal to utter a
word singers long whistle a tune I
thought had anything to do with in the
magnified or even fly the flag but even
more that is he to own the flag because
that's the thing meaning if you have a
flag in a shoe box in your closet in
your home the police can come in knock
on your door you don't open that can
break down your door find the flag maybe
they'd even plant the flag and then
you're subject to ten years imprisonment
for that
Joris to my students at Lehman they
can't believe it yeah and and and to to
create you know it great and even sort
of an additional layer of surrealism to
it George Orwell wrote 1984 in 1948 and
it was published in 1949 you know became
a best-seller in the United States and
and Great Britain so right around that
time was when lost fifty three was
promulgated and the island of Puerto
Rico was locked down they have abrogated
the First Amendment rights of again of
an entire island the two million people
- shut up one man George Orwell was
alive and well in Puerto Rico at the
same time that he was a bestseller up
here in New York so let me bring you
back to Puerto Rico for a minute and I
think that that you throughout the book
you describe an attitude of indifference
of disrespect of the US colonial regime
towards Puerto Rico and Puerto Ricans
right and I think that that's very clear
and you have just talked about it quite
a bit but I think that there are many
instances in your book not to not to say
that that wasn't the case but there are
other instances in your book when you
demonstrate that Washington was
responding to complaints brought over by
Puerto Ricans but Puerto Ricans were
lobbying on their own behalf and this is
where I want the conversation to go a
little bit cuz I'm very interested in
the ways that Puerto Ricans negotiated
this Empire you familiar with my work so
you know that that's that's what I'm
going to ask you for example in page 60
you talk about when speaking about when
writing about Governor Riley you talk
about a secession of Puerto Rican
leaders steaming up to Washington to
demand Riley's removal a grand jury
bringing formal charges against Riley
resistance then and then of course that
leads to Riley's removal and then
resistance again Gore against core which
was the next governor marches in the UPR
editorials in the press senators that
are publicly criticizing gore so these
men's were sent by presidents to govern
the island but it was the actions of
Puerto Ricans in all sectors of society
that really forced the removal of
those men and I'm wondering if it is not
a unilateral expression of power it is
not a unilateral manifestation of Empire
in Puerto Rico because Puerto Ricans
were not accessing a unilateral
expression of American power so I'm
wondering if you even with those
examples in your home book do you not
consider those expressions of resistance
in the only way but I also consider them
expressions of futility
for this reason but it goes felt so
right let me explain why I can there can
be a situation in the corner of this
room that I will acknowledge when it
becomes either too loud or inconvenient
it is there but I don't have to deal
with it until it becomes it becomes an
issue okay so so these people that were
that would be traveling up to Puerto
Rico one of them came up and saw
President Taft to talk about the
independence of Puerto Rico release a
path independence and he fell asleep and
started snoring just as an example and
it by the way was President Taft who
after being president was the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court during in
1922 when he presided over Balzac the
Puerto Rico declaring that Puerto Rico
that the Constitution didn't apply in
Puerto Rico so the fact that that people
can come up and and plead their case and
yet the United States has unilateral
disposition over it isn't isn't
persuasive to me as a statement that
that that therefore qualifies or
modifies the existence of a colonial
relationship oh I'm not saying that at
all I'm not saying that it doesn't that
it doesn't discount the fact that there
is a colonial relationship in fact I
think it's very clear that there is the
colonial relationship even today right I
mean that is not under debate what I am
asking is if this idea of a unilateral
manifestation of empire is is unclear
from even the evidence that you have
presented because you have you have of
you do Riley is gone right right yeah
but what's up for what robbery what
Riley was a disaster
no exactly I know had the brilliant idea
we do any and he was and I'll go and he
was caught with his hand in the cookie
was you know anyways law he was
appointing people that were manifestly
incompetent it was just it becomes too
much of a even the Secretary of War I
forget who it was at the time said this
is highly embarrassing exactly well
under that guy would have been fired
from a guy he was his other private
public sector experience with he was
assistant postmaster I believe in Kansas
City I wouldn't fire from the job as
assistant postmaster I mean the fact
that he was uh the fact that he was
appointed to the governorship is an
indication in the first place is it is
an indication of the lack of attention
and you know and the lack of
understanding of what's happened for
Rico he didn't know what Porto Rico was
on the map literally geographically yeah
no I understand I understand that so the
fact that occasionally when things got
to a point of just intolerable
embarrassment to the entities to the
United States government the fact that
they had to remove a fool
that was actually if it not for him that
he was almost single-handedly could of
creating revolution himself but it was
intolerable and embarrassing because
Puerto Ricans were making it that way
and I think that's my point
like I want the Puerto Ricans I want
Porto Ricans at this time not just a
visa because a visa was an incredible
voice and not just another ELISA and
they were an incredible important voice
during this time but I I want to know
what what Puerto Ricans were doing they
were not the only voice in this time
period
people were agitating people were
organizing people were marching people
were visiting presidents and Secretary
of War and Secretary of Agriculture and
everybody in Washington on a regular
basis and it wasn't just you know the
the legislature that was doing it just
regular Puerto Ricans who had affiliated
themselves so I'm wondering I want to
know more about who else had a voice
there what were poor Ricans doing
because because reading your book you
get a sense it is a story of
victimization clearly what happened to
Alvey sue was abuse what happened the
the use of the car to pay stuff was
abuse right all of these things are
abusive I wouldn't disagree with any of
that I think it's it's convincing we
know it's part of the record you have
done a phenomenal job putting it all out
there
I am wondering about Puerto Ricans I
want to try to get away from this idea
of Puerto Ricans at a distance because
it takes away power don't you think I
agree with that
however if someone has been victimized
it has to be called for what it is
because the only way to to treat a
disease is to identify it
the [ __ ] are diagnosing okay see the
source and to then apply the proper
medicine and so it is an external agent
that has been squatting and affecting
and manipulating and and extracting
wealth from a what should be a sovereign
self-sufficient people we have to
acknowledge that at no point that my
book is a testament to the resilience
and the independence and the willingness
to sacrifice on the part of member are
many people on the island of Puerto Rico
for extended period of time but it's
also a story of what's done to them when
they express that Albizu Campos being a
being a perfect example the fact that he
was in jail for 25 years basically
remind the United States of its own own
founding principles that government
exists with the consent of the
government and that all men are created
equal
to be jailed for seditious conspiracy
against the United States to then be
subjected to what is a mounting body of
evidence a mounting body of evidence
that he was tortured in jail and
subjected for something called TBI
total body radiation zone is beyond
belief and yet it's a matter of a matter
of record I looked at the FBI files I
didn't see I've been looking at the
medical reports we know from Eileen
welcome who won the Pulitzer Prize for
writing the plutonium files that before
actually wasn't the only one that they
were rough at least sixteen thousand
individuals who
unwittingly subjected to radiation
experiments many of them were prisoners
precisely during the time that I'd be
sore was it was in jail so the the fact
that people are not inherently victims I
are absolutely all for that that I'm
worth the fact that we poor Rico have
maintained our culture and our language
despite a century worth of attempts to
up to to either modify or even eliminate
it in the schools is a testament to that
inner core that's that that sense of
selfhood so for me that's a given I mean
that's not I don't even I mean I'm sorry
with it
it's obvious that I that I that I didn't
you know it didn't my party didn't been
recruit to to it didn't require argument
that Puerto Ricans are not victims okay
what Puerto Ricans have been victimized
and there has to be a recognition of
what this historical underpinnings of
that relationship have been in order to
arrive at some meaningful discussion
regarding the future absolutely no I
agree with you with that and agree with
you and I think I think one of the
interesting things about this whole time
period is that you're right to say that
the u.s. colonial project included
Americanization it was part of the
colonial project that it included a
tooless tutelage right for Puerto Ricans
who didn't know better as they say right
that it included instruction in
political democracy right and as that we
are going to be the guiding light right
I mean all of these things were part of
the American colonial project but when
they got when that project got to Puerto
Rico it it has to change constantly
because Puerto Ricans were always
demanding that it be changed in some way
or another and so my point is that it
wasn't only Venice analysis it wasn't
only the pro-independence fighters that
were arguing for a change to that policy
they were arguing or of course for the
abolition to that policy but that Puerto
Ricans in all sectors of society we're
really arguing for well we know that
this is what you think but it's not
going to work that way your your
evidence about how English failed
to become the language even though they
tried and you know a bunch of a bunch of
different laws and in a million
different ways to make it happen but we
can still speak Spanish in Puerto Rico
right this is a very clear example to me
of how the empire can have a particular
plan but that plan has to deal with a
local reality they have to deal with
Puerto Ricans who were politically savvy
they have to deal with farmers who were
organizing and lobbying Congress they
have to deal with the workers that are
affiliating right all of these sectors
of people which changes that that
whatever ideas they may have about how
the colonial project is going to look
like in Puerto Rico so so I wonder I'm
curious as to how much say and how much
and I think it was quite a bit how much
of the of the day-to-day running of
things was really in the hands of Puerto
Ricans and I think that we find evidence
that even at this time period even in
this chaotic time period of the thirty
subsets but quite a lot of it was in the
hands of Puerto Ricans not to dismiss
what happened with race or wind shape or
his abuse or any of the incidents that
you talk about any of the terrible
incidents that you talk about but I
think that we have to recognize that
there is 'm no I'm not sure more
activity in your what universe yes look
universe of things you're saying that
the Puerto Ricans are in charge of I
know that some things that they weren't
and still aren't in charge of well
Ricans are in charge of their own
maritime therefore relations the coastal
borders or kappa touch laws their
currency thanking system legal system
their laws or subjects a complete
plenary jurisdiction of the United
States and they have no federal
representatives well I'm really talking
about 1990 was like I got all over their
economic as far as within the sugarcane
economy that aspect which was dominant
as agricultural engine for about 40
years didn't have a great degree control
that before it they it clearly it was a
world market so they are yeah it wasn't
just it wasn't just abstract market
conditions do a specific banking
syndicate
it was gua Nika Fajardo South Puerto
Rico sugar before Central eventpro Rico
owned about
half of the arable land of the sugarcane
plantation and the acreage under
cultivation was about two hundred
thousand roughly which was you know I
know that the tobacco was 3040 would go
up and down but there was a dominant it
was the the dominant economic reality of
Puerto Rico was the sugar and the sugar
cane centralis so I don't I don't think
that it's a history of sufficient of
Puerto Rican control they were divested
of control that's part of the problem
Puerto Rico was an island that has its
legs taken away from it in a series of
crutches I've been to have substituted
that one decade after another operation
bootstrap which Vito Marcantonio called
operation booby-trapped 936 all sorts of
corporate incentives has been a red
carpet stretching from Wall Street to
song one for 117 years and the net
result of which has not been the read
the building of an indigenous
manufacturing Basin in Puerto Rico it's
been a series of short-term capital
intensive tax abatement deals for
foreign investment the most recent
iteration of which is act 22 under which
john paulson and other hedge fund
traders get to come to Puerto Rico and
receive a 20 year tax abatement complete
20 year tax abatement an interest
dividend and capital gains income at the
same time that Puerto Ricans are facing
an IVA to gasoline types gasoline hikes
in the past tax hikes in one year water
and electrical rates going up property
to add small business taxes have risen
they've even discussed the fat tax in
Puerto Rico it's come to the point where
Puerto Ricans cannot sustain this and
they're leaving the island at the same
time that New Yorker magazine Bloomberg
News The Wall Street Journal in The New
York Times are like the carnival barkers
for real estate interests there there's
there exists there's this horde of
people that are coming under act 20 to
the primaries of the the best model
which is john paulson who made fifteen
billion dollars in the year 2007 for his
hedge fund fund betting against the
american economy through our BRB a RMBS
real estate
our real estate real property backs
mortgage-backed securities and acid and
credit default swaps these these fancy
financial instruments were actually
based upon people losing their mortgages
well this is what happened in Puerto
Rico this man now is starting a 500
million dollar resort complex in Dorado
beach and bringing over other syndicates
of investors in Puerto Rico under the
auspices of act 22 so that same sort of
predatory capitalism from 2007 where he
made fifteen billion dollars during the
mortgage crisis is now being imported
into Puerto Rico under the auspices of a
20-year tax abatement so this is no
different in a sense from the the the
the banking syndicates that came in and
appropriated puerto rican land and just
sat back in Wall Street as the Charles
Herbert Allen the first civilian
Governor of Puerto Rico he saved your 17
months that was it then he resigned what
quickly went to Wall Street and
installed himself as a treasurer than
president that a member of the board of
directors of the American Sugar Refining
Company which we now know was Domino
sugar he was like an economic hitman he
came and he cased the island and turned
it into a crime scene because he goes
back and becomes a president of Morgan
Guaranty Trust and sets up these banking
syndicates and the people that he had
appointed into the Puerto Rican
government bureaucracy during those 17
months gave him federal favorable water
easements tax abatements deals
preferential treatment in land
disposition it because he had these
relationships and people that he could
call in Puerto Rico he was given sort of
a red carpet as I said before to
basically be one of the people that led
the charge and taking over the Puerto
Rican economy back then in the same way
that John Paulson is now so I'm sort of
going on Alessia but I think that
there's been I am here there's been a
history of continuous disinvestment and
to just sort of bring it back to and
then to wrap it up the benefit of Bull
Connor is that you could see the fire
hydrants and
dogs and you can take a photograph the
vent is a perverse been a bit of a
police chief Riggs is that he would
utter words as fantastic as uh and and
surreal as there is a war against all
Puerto Ricans when his pills police shot
four people three opiate us when the
Ponte Ponte Massacre killed seventeen
unarmed men women and children that were
just simply marching on Palm Sunday
Infante in support of a visa Campos and
in recognition of the National Party
singing level in Kenya the Puerto Rican
national anthem that was their crime
well then it's more naked and you could
see the the the teeth of that empire now
it's a little more subtle now it's not
it's not it's not obviously at the point
of a gun it's from a briefcase it's from
a it's from a stock offering that's
that's done in Wall Street that ends up
expropriating huge amounts of Puerto
Rican property and yet it's the same net
result it's just a lot subtler yeah I
think that one of the one of the
interesting things to point out is that
and that has also been studied by it by
other scholars this is the
criminalization of the independence
movement which is something that you
document really well in this book right
how to be affiliated with the
independence movement within us analysis
became a crime and I wonder I have been
reading quite a bit about this lately to
prepare for this interview but I also
wonder in my classes my students always
ask me why is there not more agitation
in Puerto Rico for independence clearly
it is a colonial system it is not a
secret that it's a colonial system even
with participation we know that it's a
colonial system so why is there not more
agitation and I think clearly part of
that is the criminalization of being an
independent activist but I was wondering
if you could comment perhaps on on that
half it has the independence party in
your in your
in all of your studies what happened
other than the criminalization of it
that really at the end of the day we
don't have an organized numerous healthy
independence movement on the island well
the more visible event events were some
that I that I decided that he Opia that
as Massacre here
I intend the Banzai massacre and people
just being gunned down in the street
just and without much apology or
explanation some other very visible
moments were when the Nationalists had
their which is a one of the major events
in the subject matter of my book the
Revolution of 1950 we spread through
eight towns and included an attempt in
la Fortaleza on the governor's mansion
the fact that the way that the United
States reacted immediately they they
deployed 5000 National Guardsmen they
arrested three thousand 400 Ricans in
the space of a week and they bombed two
towns and they bombed two towns in broad
daylight they scrambled ten p-47 fighter
planes and bomb the towns of Hialeah and
twaddle the only time in American
history that the United States
intentionally willingly knowingly
bombards its own its own citizens so
those are the high points that people
are aware that it can get to that point
that if you if you take it to if you
escalate it the United States response
will be immediate effective coordinated
and the Puerto Rico especially at the
time was separated from the mainland by
a couple of thousand miles of ocean from
New York to from New York and Washington
to Puerto Rico separated by an ocean a
language culture 400 years of eva'dur
American history and technology the
technology was important because there
was no certainly no internet no
television we're talking about the 50s
40s 30s some radio but the only thing
that got off the island was controlled
by say half a dozen wire service
reporters AP and you
ti reporters that were basically
American reporters reporting and they
would just see their stories to the
United mainstream newspapers at Wall
Street Journal the New York Times and
they would sort of regurgitate a
prepackaged story so as an example in
the Banzai massacre it was reported up
here as a nationalist riot yes and they
did and and then that was in the head
Rodriquez riot then in the by in the in
the text they would say that there was a
gunfight well the word gunfight is its
definitional a fight involved two sides
but there can't be a gunfight if you
don't have any guns
we're unarmed Porto Ricans in the
Poinsettia massacre so it wasn't it was
the knowledge that this violence could
be sudden swift and severe and that no
matter what you did it was going to be
misreported and and you're you're you
were living in a complete vacuum down
there so that was what one so there were
these peaks of violence yeah
but then but then as an everyday reality
you have the two dynamics that perfectly
exemplify what people were living
through public log 53 which I mentioned
before was passed by this window smiting
very quickly after decent compost came
back from prison with his specific if
the proposal intent was that it was an
anti-communist measure and it it closely
correlated to the to the language of the
sniff Act in in the United States but
there weren't any communist is no Soviet
menace in Puerto Rico it was clear that
it was intended to disciple and to
corral Albizu Campos the fact that you
have a law that criminalizes as you said
free speech anything that you say any
word literally sing a song I wrote word
whistle attune that is that that gets
into you into your character into your
perm this way into your psyche and you
look at the other elements besides Pablo
53 is that that badass program because
that's where secret police dossier that
were maintained on over a hundred
thousand Puerto Rico
over a six decade period from the early
to mid 30s right after the agricultural
strike this is when it happened this is
when J Edgar Hoover was given the
instructions go ahead we need to now
contain this problem in Puerto Rico
after that strike those six decades when
you create a hundred thousand files on
people it's not just the files you think
of it the deed the think of the file as
an organism how does that get created
well the FBI and the police couldn't
create it they had to it has to be
reported to them sure I was locked in my
performance
yeah and so now you have a situation
where the FBI is actively turning
brother against brother in Puerto Rico
you have a hundred thousand files you
have tens of thousands of the
performance and the way that you get
those informants it's not because Berto
Ricans are inherently treacherous you
would worm your way in you would call
someone in to the precinct on some on
some pretext and say we heard such a
such and such and I think was an open a
file on you as a guy will panic but then
they'll put your arm around them that's
a carrot in the stick but you know what
we don't believe it we think you were
actually a good guy you're one of us and
we're one of the same thing but the way
you know we're gonna believe that that
you're you know you're not a seditious
conspirator whatever because you're
going to come back and you're gonna tell
us about those other bad guys you're a
good guy you're with us but now that we
have you on whatever initial pretext now
we need to going to turn you and and
it's a very easy process
you have dealing with very end and it's
cancerous it's viral so when you have
that going on for 60 years you're
looking at two to three complete
generations of Puerto Rican history
people are born and raised with this as
their living waking reality one
generation after the next so that sense
of looking over your shoulder of the
visitors of factionalism of the
innovative obstacles to creating your
solidarity of a sense of fatalism that
on top of that you'll go to jail if you
know you got that value and now there's
law 53 if you set a few other other work
and on top of that if you want to get
even
or testy about it we'll shoot you
because we you know we declared war
against Auto Regas and if you go even
further we'll bomb you exactly so you
add all that together and when you have
people that are naturally it has a sense
of constraint it is very it is
inculcated and it's bred and it becomes
part of the DNA of a bit of people to
not create that one solid unified
overwhelming prepossessing and
indomitable voice that has to be heard
and finally just realize that especially
historically back then even if you had
that voice it wouldn't get off the
island
ivory some composted revolution in 1950
we're not really a military act
they just bomb Nagasaki and Hiroshima
the most powerful empire in the history
of the world they were trying to just
make a dramatic statement so that the UN
Committee on decolonization could become
aware that was a very real palpable
issue on the island that needed to be
addressed before the 1952 cleveson vote
and before the 1950 vote which was
creating the path to that plunder that
plenty and that common well said so so
there is um there's a history of trying
to get this with message off the island
and that was all these accomplices
message to both Puerto Rico and the
world that we need to I that there's
something wrong that this relationship
isn't working and people need to hear it
mm-hmm yeah no I agree with you and I
think that I I wonder also if you ran
into any evidence on we don't have a lot
of time left but just as a quick as a
quick aside you know I I have been
reading about you know we are coming to
an election year and a parties are going
to put out their platforms and in Puerto
Rico this is always a almost like a
sporting event right elections in Puerto
Rico and I wonder if the the
independence activists have been unable
for the past several elections to even
get enough votes to to even be in the in
the ballot officially without having to
lobby for it without having to have
signatures for it so I
wonder if there is something at work
here too and I suspect that there may be
dad dad the party perhaps has not put
forth a vision that people can buy into
so perhaps this is a call this book is
part of a call to understand the past -
then get us ready to move towards the
future maybe an awakening perhaps of
sorts through everybody in Puerto Rico -
to look at our history with new eyes and
to really understand where we have been
but you mentioned at the end what some
of your interviews I've heard that you
have argued that the future of the
island needs to be negotiated with all
of this information in our hands and
that this is part of our history and I
agree and I think that that needs to
happen from a position of power and on
your book is part of that getting us
that into that position of power but I
think I would like to hear some last
words about what you think about this
about being in a position of power well
I want to give I thank you for this
moment I want to give recognition to
Luis Gonzalez I believe argüello
Gonzalez who came forward from the
island to translate this into Spanish
Robert Canyon pero no hablo you know
there's algo del otro mundo and Luis are
great for Gonzales of his own own
volition with a tremendous degree of
passion has been translating this book
in his on chapter 17 at the game and I
also want to recognize that Carlos
Carlos Cheeseman Carlos Gonzales Carlos
Reyes Aponte no Kairos Reyes Alonso I'm
sorry I'm Scott Walker gonna be Carlos
Reyes Alonso is one a leader of the VIP
the Puerto Rican independence party and
he's reached out to me and he's been
coordinating a multi-city tour
engagement for the book which isn't to
me very and this happened really quickly
there Carlos Reyes alone so contacted me
and contacted other members of the pip2
them that Rios has read the book and the
fact that they
very quickly they were integrated the
the the facts and they the worldview
that is that is shown as shown in this
book and and that they were they're
ready to deal from a point of view as
you said from power information it's
probably the most important galvanizing
element at this point especially with
all the economic turmoil that's happened
in Puerto Rico by the way I heard a
great great interview by a woman named
maria lourdes de santiago Negron okay
she's a senator in the in puerto rico
and she's an independent she's a member
of the VIP she is so eloquent so
specific so detailed it was an you can
look at on Oliva I know it's not a
commercial plug but it was on a show
called dossier okay and the interview
was a man named William Martinez and so
if you simply google the words maria
luiza santiago Negron dossier interview
you it's an hour long interview and man
was she so on point with her with the
tying in of not only the historical
men's but the political under currents
that are there that are that are running
through puerto rico now and the
historicity of our party and in a sense
the inevitability of some of the
dynamics that are happening in in puerto
rico
you're right that you know electoral ii
it's an odd thing and it derives partly
from the history it derives from the
fact that the the pee pee pee they are
the two majority parties they have is a
lock hold on the electoral system very
much like a Democrats in the Republicans
here but they've lost the narrative of
the island because what they have what
they've the the truth of the matter the
concrete fact is if the island is adrift
right now right now its equivalent to if
you remember the movie Rocky where Rocky
is you've seen triple and and his
manager Mickey says hit the guy in the
middle that's what happening they don't
know which direction they're turning
because it's rudderless they should be
looking at things like the cava Tosh
laws that Merchant Marine act of coming
920 yeah they should there's some
specific things that they can
aggressively agree upon and work but in
fact instead you have one party
submitting impeachment petitions against
against the other and the message I get
that that it goes out is that both
parties are divided and dripping with
self-interest that isn't that that's not
the double working and they're fighting
over what it may be of currently
untenable proposition of statehood for
Puerto Rico which although there are
some benefits there are so many
constitutional and economic and and
economic obstacles to that that it's not
even it shouldn't be the center of the
debate the sheller debate right now is
how to resolve the public debt of Puerto
Rico and how to work the cava Tosh law
differently exactly and that does not
belong to any party it belongs to all of
us Porto Ricans this one it's been a
pleasure thank you for joining us and
good luck with support congratulations
on your book tour in Puerto Rico thank
you gotcha